um assistant XOXO that's really about
classic okay it's a pie but Mr okay hi
this is my last one that before i show
you what this substitution is they will
they will tell you what the substitution
is but before eyes give it to you what
would you guess the substitution or to
be because there's actually enough
information in this sort of yes hmm what
would you put there by the way I give
you a tip we're in harder trig integrals
right there will be a trig function of
some kind the question is which one um
it's going to be signed okay here's how
I know number one is a square root here
okay so it's either going to be sine or
cosine it was tan there'd be no square
root okay secondly I'm positive and
signs the one that's climbing okay but
anyone they'll tell you what it is so in
a sense this doesn't matter but let in
fact it's the same as the last question
x equals sine 2 sine theta okay now
you'll notice this is an indefinite
integral so that's sweet I don't have to
worry about boundaries but I start to
worry about this DX business ok so again
I'll say the actual equation I've got
there the actual theme i'm integrating
rather is this condo x's got X Squared's
oh ok so I'll square that that it gives
in the same thing same result I had
before I'll differentiate so that I can
sub DX out and again I get the same
result as before ok but this x squared
on the top rather complicates things ok
so let's have a go throw it over all the
pieces I need to shove out so for sine
squared is what going on the top sorry
yeah that's right what's that's good
that DX as well is also on the top
really so I'm going to put that as well
that's 2 cos theta D theta
because dafina okay and that's all over
4 plus 4 so it'd be just like it was the
last case ok now let's have a look at
wait one second before plus sorry I'm
sorry that's a minus that we work my
brain my brain was thinking wait that's
not the right that's not the right
identity ok mine is gonna change now
just like before this is going to turn
into that for when you bring it out will
become a to outside the square root and
then you have one minus sine squared
which is just cause right so I'm going
to get to cause which is what i have
here as well ok so this is i'll just
write out the whole thing to cos theta
d-theta on too close they are ok so you
canceled and you're thinking sweet what
do you mean this is harder than the
previous one ok well let's keep going to
see what happens so let's go ahead again
we've got to use that double bond to
simplify this into something like an
integrate ok so this is going to be four
times half half what 1 minus cos 2x ok
so that four and a half four times are
off will be 2 1 minus cos 2x sorry Peter
defeater okay okay almost there again
that to actually be useful to me because
when I use reverse channel that's just
become site with it up ok so 2 theta
minus sine 2 theta plus C ok now usually
we tend to think of um eat indefinite
integrals as less work than definite
integrals because definite integrals are
the same thing but you just have to put
in some values right so it's just a few
extra steps you have to do but here in
definite integrals are actually more
work can anyone see why
yeah I'm not done yet right this this
answer here it's all integrated that
kind of thing but it's still in terms of
this magic substitution that are just
introduced okay has nothing to do the
exes that the original question was in
terms of okay so I've got to do some
legwork here is kind of a fair bit to
actually get this back in terms of exit
okay so let's continue over here I've
got a to theater now we gotta say [ __ ]
let's do the first one first how i get
rid of theta my substitution was this
right so what am I gonna have to do to
get figure into it yeah I'm going to
have to use inverse functions right so
i'll take the 20 Vigo side this leads to
exon 2 sine theta right see if I'm feet
up is this okay all right so far so good
so i can substitute that feed on there
as 2 sine inverse of X on too okay all
right so far so good now I got a sine 2
theta now hmm I could just say that's
sine x to slow down a second to okay I
could do that but for reasons to have
become clear in about 30 seconds it's
actually a bit counterintuitive to do
that so I'm actually going to first I'll
expand sine 2 theta we all know the
substitution for the expansion for
Sergio Vieira is 2 sine theta cos theta
right and don't forget you're confident
keeps on hanging on okay okay now
illumise there when I put in theta here
right it's going to be sine inverse of X
1 to 2 sine inverse of X onto minus all
right this is going to get rather large
so stay with me sign of actually should
probably come Square sign off sine
inverse X on to
and close of sine inverse X on 2 plus
our poor learner Cliff Lee ok so what do
I do now